science is beautiful it's it's
absolutely beautiful ideas but we can
also really bring an aesthetic to it
which makes it so much more impactful
and can allow your ideas to have a much
greater reach data visualization
infographics are now in every newspaper
in the country in many ways this seems
like a very very new phenomenon but it
actually has a very interesting and very
rich history
this diagram here by Florence
Nightingale is truly one of those
diagrams that has actually changed the
world it's changed science it's changed
the way in which things were done many
people think of Florence Nightingale is
the lady with the lamp but she was
actually an incredibly Amanat
statistician in her own right and during
the Crimean War she gathered data about
how people were dying the red on this
diagram is the wounds and in blue here
that's all
preventable diseases basically acquired
in hospital conditions
what's really quite remarkable here is
that she shows that by implementation of
sanitary reforms you have a really
dramatic reduction in the number of
deaths that were occurring due to poor
sanitary conditions in hospitals this
was a very political diagram that she
gave to all sorts of government
ministers etc with the specific
intention of driving through massive
public health reforms the human genome
is an incredibly complex thing as
absolutely massive amounts of data here
what we're doing is comparing the human
genome to that of a chimpanzee a dog a
chicken and a platypus each of these
circles is a different chromosome so
we've got our 22 and then we've got X
and y chromosomes and on the top we've
got the animal genome and then on the
bottom we've got the human chromosome
and all of these colored areas are areas
of genomics and molarity
these diagrams are actually published
all the time in the scientific
literature where scientists are looking
for connections between genes and
different diseases trying to actually
reconstruct the Tree of Life in
different and interesting ways it's not
something where you automatically know
what's going on but they draw you and
you say oh what's going on here and then
you actually see and I think that's
quite important
I first encountered this visualization
year or two ago at a scientific
conference where NASA had a stand and I
was just absolutely gobsmacked by this I
mean that this what we're looking here
is ocean currents and this is based on
both satellite data as well as things
like ocean buoys and so on the great
thing about this video is it really
captures the dynamic nature of our
oceans and really emphasizes very
beautifully I think the way in which
these global ocean currents actually
work in a very dynamic way in which a
simple still of an ocean model wouldn't
really do data visualization it's not at
all taking away from the science or the
data that's actually within them it's
it's not something where you're
substituting form for function but
you've got both form and function in
these diagrams and I think that's what
makes them so powerful